[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com there was a horrible and
tragic shooting over the weekend in a
sense it was really sort of two mass
shootings at al-nour mosque and at
Linwood Islamic Center mosque in
Christchurch New Zealand at this point
we believe that 50 people were killed
and another 50 people were injured we
know that the alleged shooter is a 28
year old white supremacist who lives
streamed the first attack has been
arrested and charged with murder and as
soon as we got our hands on the alleged
shooter 73 page manifesto that he left
behind it became very clear that whether
or not this shooter was specifically
motivated to violence by Donald Trump as
an individual there was no doubt that
the rhetoric and ideology that was
compelling to the shooter
matches that which we've seen coalesced
by Donald Trump and this is effectively
undeniable and there have been all sorts
of Defense's which we will talk about
momentarily but when you look at the
manifesto and you see the conspiracy
theories that there's a white genocide
happening or about to happen when you
see the extreme anti-immigrant sentiment
describing himself as an
ethno-nationalism us looms referencing
Donald Trump as a quote symbol of
renewed white identity and common
purpose those who want to separate Trump
from this incident point out well hold
on the shooter wrote in their manifesto
that they don't support Trump as a
policy maker it's not a defense okay
just I mean cut it that that's just
the ridiculous defense every white
supremacist says that they don't see
Trump as a path to white supremacist
policy they see him as generally
renewing and fomenting the conditions
and atmosphere in which white supremacy
has a better chance of growing and
expanding when I interviewed white
nationalist Richard Spencer a couple
years ago at this point he literally
said it to me in almost those exact
words during an interview it's not that
Trump is going to do the thing it's that
he's the closest that they've had and
he's sort of allowed this environment to
foment so those who want to separate
Trump from this incident say the shooter
was an eco fascist who believes in
global warming hate to break it to you
most people believe in global warming at
this point especially in the rest of the
developed world climate change I should
better call it in the United States
right-wing extremists often don't accept
the climate science but in a lot of the
world you can both recognize that
climate change is real and still be a
right-wing white nationalist extremist
in the United States
it's where the two seem to go together
only very rarely but most importantly we
don't have to just look at what Trump
has said before the shooting and then at
what the shooters manifesto said even
after the shooting in New Zealand Donald
Trump continued to use verbatim the same
language of the shooter visa vie an
immigration invasion Trump said oh yeah
it's a horrible thing of course and then
he immediately turned back to
immigration and the language of calling
immigrants an invasion which is exactly
the rhetoric of the shooter we actually
have a bit of video here of Donald Trump
talking about this and you will see him
very quickly go back to the same stuff
that seems to have motivated the shooter
it is a tremendous national emergency it
is a tremendous crisis last month more
than 76,000 illegal migrants arrived at
our border we're on track for a million
illegal aliens to rush our borders
people hate the word invasion but
what it is it's an invasion of drugs and
criminals and people we have no idea who
they are
so understand what he's saying here the
shooting was bad but the shooter was
right in that there is an immigration
invasion this is the rhetoric that has
pervaded the 19th century in 28th 20th
century xenophobic movement but it
matches up Trump and the shooter the New
Zealand shooter and Trump using almost
identical language the New Zealand
shooter saying we are experiencing an
invasion on a level never seen before in
history Donald Trump not only sang
people hate the word invasion but that's
what it is but Donald Trump clearly
believes that this is a worse quote
invasion than we've had in a long time
because he declared a national emergency
around it one that is absolutely and
utterly bogus the relevant mechanism
here is called stochastic terrorism I've
spoken about this before this is when
you publicly demonize a person an
institution a group and what happens
statistically is the likely motivation
of an individual to commit violent acts
it's statistically probable but you
can't predict who will do it when you
think back to that right-wing host Glenn
Beck who maybe you've forgotten about at
this point and when he would always go
on and on about the evils of the tides
foundation it was not a terrorism in the
sense that he was specifically telling
an audience member to go and try to
attack the tides foundation but his
audience was big enough that it became
statistically likely that someone would
be inspired to commit violence against
the tides foundation and indeed someone
did and they were caught I believe it
was with weapons on a highway before
they were actually able to commit that
act of violence stochastic terrorism is
the term here and incredibly I'm going
to be talking about it twice on today's
program including in the next story I
was actually going to cover this story
earlier in today's show except then
Trump's violent rhetoric was actually
linked
to a specific shooting the one in New
Zealand but shortly before the shooting
in New Zealand Donald Trump issued the
type of threat that we hear from
authoritarian dictators about using the
police and the military to crack down
against political opponents which is of
course completely antithetical to
everything that the United States stands
for or at least should stand for this
actually wasn't noticed for a few days
Donald Trump gave an interview to
Breitbart it was early last week in fact
and at a certain point in this interview
he said supporters of his might get
tough on people who oppose him
politically this includes the military
this includes the police and this
includes biker gangs now I'm going to
show you
bright Bart's own transcript of what
Trump said this isn't a summary this
isn't some left-wing website rephrasing
what Donald Trump said this is bright
Bart's
transcript of what Donald Trump said
they conducted the interview Donald
Trump said quote it's so terrible what's
happening you know the left plays a
tougher game it's very funny I actually
think that the people on the right are
tougher but they don't play it tougher
okay so far it's unintelligible by the
way Trump goes on I can tell you I have
the support of the police the support of
the military the support of the bikers
for Trump I have the tough people and
they don't play it tough until they go
to a certain point and then it would be
very bad very bad but the left plays it
cuter and tougher so let's put aside for
a second the New Zealand shooting that
took place over the weekend even without
that we now have exactly the type of
comment that we can add to Trump's
subtle and sometimes not so subtle
fomenting of political violence remember
that in the United States political
violence exists almost exclusively by
the right okay this is Trump sort of
foreshadowing physical confrontations I
guess based on what he's saying
between left-wing protesters who are
almost exclusively
and Donald Trump's biker gangs as well
as the military and the police now you
might say hold on David Trump says
police and military but he doesn't mean
that the police and military are going
to enforce Trump's political views with
violence they are simply for law and
order if the left becomes violent in
their opposition to Donald Trump income
the military and the police and they
will simply enforce the law wrong okay
that's a ridiculous defense police have
a job to enforce the law period the fact
that they support Trump politically
which Trump is bringing up should have
no place or importance in the fact that
if people break the law the police will
step in now as far as even mentioning
the military the military is not
supposed to be used for domestic law
enforcement period there's something
from 1878 called the Posse Comitatus Act
comet ATIS not exactly sure how it's
pronounced which limits the use of the
federal government to use the military
for domestic policy enforcement or
domestic law enforcement when Trump
mentions even the possibility of using
the military in this way it's outrageous
and once again once you talk about as
Trump says the military is on his side
you're wading into very dangerous and
possibly illegal territory and I was
thinking Pat if you look at who uses the
military to enforce their political
positions it's not good company it's
exactly the authoritarian types that
were concerned Trump is so impressed and
enamored with yeah this absolutely
sounds to me like a veiled threat it's
kind of like Trump saying I could beat
you up if I wanted to but I'm going to
show restraint and I'm not going to
I certainly hope it never comes to this
I hope we never see the police and the
military and the biker gangs fighting
against the people but if there is ever
time that it gets to that it maybe if
Trump loses the election and wants to
fight back in some way doesn't want to
go down and I hope it never gets to that
but I think we're gonna talk about that
a little later in the show yeah we are
we've talked about that before we
talk about it again and and just to put
finalized so we've got the police and
the military then the biker gangs that
we're now kind of getting into the realm
of the absurd but Vladimir Putin has
actually used the Russian nationalist
biker gang called the night wolves who
are funded in part by the Kremlin to do
all sorts of political stuff in Russia
it's really vile it probably impresses
Donald Trump and once again these
comments I won't reacquaint stochastic
terrorism is but these are the types of
comments that would fall under the
umbrella of stochastic terrorism
publicly demonizing or threatening a
person or group which statistically
makes it likely that someone will go and
act out what it is that is being
suggested in this case political
violence by biker gangs the police and
military against the political opponents
of Donald Trump Donald Trump Trump
that's an interesting one very dangerous
stuff and I want to hear from you about
it what is your reaction in terms of
Trump's rhetoric to the New Zealand
shooting what is your reaction to Donald
Trump's thinly veiled threats to use the
police and the military and biker gangs
to crack down on political opponents by
the way political opponents that Trump
hasn't even said are violent I mean we
know that most of trumps political
opponents aren't violent the political
violence is coming from the right trumps
not even saying that this would be in
response to violence he's saying this
would be against his political opponents
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show
follow me let me know what you think and
we'll follow up on it later in the beat
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new member of the day
is david our heart David thank you so
much for being a supporter of the show
we are mostly supported by members like
David Earhart and someone who's been a
member for a long time now Bernard Sant
our CEO who's been with us nearly five
years five years of membership for
Bernard join David and Bernard @ww join
pakman.com the normal membership rates
extraordinarily reasonable if I do say
so myself but if you want to chop them
down by an additional 40% you can use
the coupon code this is 20/20 this is to
zero to zero all lowercase no spaces
this is 20/20 it'll drop the cost of
membership any membership by 40% you get
100% of the member benefits at a 40%
discount check it out okay we have heard
from Harvard Law Professor Lawrence
tribe who is sounding the alarm that he
believes Donald Trump is not going to
leave the presidency peacefully in 2020
and might specifically use bogus
national emergency declarations to
justify his re-election as a sort of
October Surprise type of thing so let's
step back before we get into Lawrence
tribes comments and kind of think about
the context for a moment there was
discussion when Barack Obama was
president of Obama declaring Martial Law
to prevent the 2016 election from
happening and to stay in power
indefinitely there was the idea of
Donald of Barack Obama I don't even know
not holding the 2016 election in some
other way or using some kind of arcane
legal mechanism to try to become
president for life now it was ridiculous
there was no merit to any of those
accusations Barack Obama had never said
anything of the sort Barack Obama did
not have authoritarian tendencies under
Donald Trump on the other hand we're
hearing similar allegations the
difference being that Trump does have a
pattern
in history of those authoritarian
tendencies particularly related to the
fairness of elections Barack Obama never
suggested that president-for-life would
be nice which is something that Donald
Trump has said Donald Trump has talked
about Hillary Clinton getting three
million illegal votes started a voter
integrity commission election integrity
commission to look into it with no
evidence it found no evidence but Donald
Trump was willing to spend untold amount
of money in order to do that Donald
Trump refused to say that he would
accept election results that showed he
lost to Hillary Clinton in 2016
he has other authoritarian tendencies
that we've discussed not directly
related to elections we've seen over the
last few weeks some of his flunkies like
Sarah Huckabee Sanders the press
secretary start to float the idea that
Trump could only lose via some kind of
voter or election fraud or foul play in
2020 which is of course an in defeasible
argument you can't possibly argue
against that if someone is asserting
that Michael Cohen said he's worried
that Donald Trump will not relinquish
control of the Oval Office if indeed he
loses in 2020 we've already done a
segment talking about how it's unlikely
in practice that it would actually be
allowed to happen by the military and by
law enforcement but all of these ideas
relate to ways that one might
hypothetically illegally seized power or
refused to relinquish it Lawrence tribe
brings us a different idea the idea
Lawrence tribe presented on MSNBC over
the weekend is that Donald Trump we know
he's willing to file to declare bogus
national emergencies over things that
are not actually emergencies or crises
the situation at the us-mexico border
being our example right now Donald Trump
Lawrence tribe suggests would use a
bogus national emergency declaration to
create a type of fear that would maybe
get him reelected in November of 2020
that's the idea here is Harvard Law
Professor Lawrence tribe saying it
himself we can't count on his being
voted out of office in 2020 he is
sufficiently corrupt and will probably
have enough help from not to friendly
foreign powers Russia Saudi Arabia maybe
Turkey so that we can't count on
removing this guy by an election and in
fact he may fabricate yet another
so-called national emergency to
influence that election what we have to
do is persistently gather the facts
right so what he is saying is not that
it would be an illegal seizure of the
White House or a refusal to accept the
results he's saying Trump could use
bogus national emergencies to get
reelected and of course in a country
where half the country doesn't vote half
the population doesn't vote and so many
people are voting based on incorrect
understandings of the world around them
it's not only plausible but it's
extraordinarily feasible to actually do
now any president could do this right
any president as their term as their
first term is nearing an end and with a
reelection in doubt could do it but I
believe Pat that it's different with
Trump because he has a history of having
no problem lying about what even
constitutes an emergency many presidents
exaggerates the seriousness of
situations but Donald Trump has created
some of this whole cloth including with
the us-mexico border and importantly we
know that Trump supporters and his base
will 100% uncritically accept whatever
emergency declaration Trump makes so I
think that this is a more likely
scenario that Lawrence tribe points out
not that Trump will illegally refused to
leave the oval office but that we he
will engineer some kind of false
situation to justify his re-election
which will work yeah I think this is
more of an interesting conversation
sometimes we do talk about if Trump will
willingly vacate the Oval Office if he
does lose the election and I often think
that that is putting the cart before the
horse like we have to find out if he's
actually going to lose the election
first we have to have the election and
we should focus on that but if he
prematurely declares the National number
urgency knowing that it's going to
garner him some support may put him over
the top that I do think we have to
actually think about it what that
emergency would be on the other hand I
don't know is it going to be something
more like a false flag or is it going to
be him making a mountain out of a
molehill like we did with this last one
on immigration well the most important
consideration no matter what it would be
is that Trump can't do any of this stuff
without Republican support or at least
Republican indifference because if
Donald Trump does fabricate any kind of
bogus emergency if Republicans don't
allow it right it's not veto-proof if
Trump declares a bogus emergency and the
House and Senate vote it down and Trump
vetoes that vote that veto can be
overridden if and this is the important
if Republicans decide they're not going
to allow Trump to use national
emergencies to try to get himself
reelected at this point the Republican
Party has demonstrated itself to be so
corrupt that they are likely to allow
Donald Trump to do whatever because of
so-called party unity or because a
Democrat would be worth or whatever
specious justification they come up with
so I think that this is a much greater
danger than the sort of cartoonish Trump
barricades himself in the Oval Office
and refuses to leave here's a two-part
question who are you supporting for the
2020 Democratic nomination and do you
actually like that person there's a
really interesting new likability poll
from Quinnipiac University that people
have been emailing me about and asking
me to comment on and to summarize the
results of this Quinnipiac poll on
Democratic candidate likability every
single candidate has a net dislike a
what are called net unfavorable rating
other than Joe Biden who isn't even
actually a 20/20 candidate as of right
now now by the way please don't write to
me angrily about what I'm telling you
here I'm just the messenger
I'm not saying anything positive or
negative about Joe Biden or any of the
other candidates here I'm just
discussing the poll results with you
before I start getting angry messages
about this the measure the metric is
called net net favorability if more
people have a favorable rather than
unfavorable view of you that's called
net favorability if
more people dislike you it's called net
unfavorability so let's look at the
results for the Democratic candidates
among all voters and then among
Democrats you will notice that among all
voters Joe Biden has a plus 14
likability ratio whereas every other
Democratic candidate Booker not
everybody's included in this poll but
the ones that are Booker Gillibrand
Harris Hickenlooper Inslee Klobuchar or
Roark Sanders and Warren have anywhere
from a minus four to a minus eighteen
favorability net favorability rating now
I'm going to come back to that in a
second on the Democratic side you will
notice if you look just among Democrats
everybody but jay Inslee has at least
some net favorability Joe Biden would
the highest net favorability followed by
Kamala Harris then Elizabeth Warren
Bernie Sanders and beto Aurora but let's
go back again because we're thinking now
in terms of the general election if you
look at the net unfavorability among all
voters of most of these candidates what
you will notice is that a lot of these
candidates aren't really very well known
so when you look at Amy Klobuchar for
example she has an 11th 11 percent
favorable 16 percent unfavorable that
gets her minus 5 most people haven't
even heard of Amy Klobuchar so what we
are seeing right now I believe Pat is
that this is an artifact of lack of name
recognition the more well-known a
candidate is right now the more negative
their favorability is other than Joe
Biden who again isn't even a candidate
right now so my prediction is that these
numbers are simply too early to tell us
very much about who is actually likable
on the Democratic side that may
certainly be true the Bernie Sanders won
at least at this stage is surprising to
me because I always thought that
Republicans and people who disagree with
Bernie on policy still view him
favorably because they think of him as
honest maybe maybe or maybe not the
other thing I thought
is that I think you're seeing so much
unfavorability because you're mixing in
both Republicans and people who are on
the right with people who are on the
left but don't support one particular
candidate so like if you ask me if I
have a favorable view of Amy Klobuchar
or bethe Aurora core Cory Booker some of
these corporatist Democrats I may say no
and that pulls moon with the Republicans
too so overall you're going to have this
net unfavorability I think that's what
it is at this stage but of course if you
get to the general election and it's
Klobuchar versus Trump or Booker versus
Trump I'm gonna go with the Democrat
that's an interesting point which is
that Republicans just don't like any of
these people if they've heard of them
whereas Democrats who may be more
familiar with them are actually taking a
more nuanced view based on who they're
likely to support in a primary even if
they'd vote for any or almost any of
these candidates if they were to be the
nominees the Joe Biden thing yeah I
think Biden's benefiting from being
remembered sort of favorably from the
Obama presidency particularly in
contrast to the Trump administration the
sort of affable sidekick to Barack Obama
it's not
I believe that Biden is seen as a
progressive leader particularly since
he's pretty moderate on a lot of issues
but for the for the time being I would
not read too much into this Biden is up
but other people are liked by Democrats
and in the immediate what we need to
figure out is who's going to be the
Democratic nominee eventually yes you're
going to need some Democratic challenger
to trump that's not acutely disliked
just being disliked a little less than
Trump is probably not going to be enough
to win especially when half the country
doesn't vote but I wouldn't read too
much into these numbers for the time
being make sure you're following the
David Pakman show on Instagram at David
Pakman show while you're there follow me
at David Pakman we will take a break
speaking of Bernie Sanders Ben Cohen of
Ben and Jerry's Fame joins me next to
talk about the Bernie Sanders candidacy
and being a national co-chair for Bernie
and we'll talk about some of the cases
being made
gangsta burns this time that's coming up
after the break the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome back to the
program today Ben Cohen who is the
co-founder of Ben & Jerry's and also a
national co-chair for Bernie Sanders
2020 campaign
he's known Bernie for for a long time
right I mean how long have you known him
at this point I you know I guess I've
known Bernie for about 40 years Ben and
Jerry started out at about the same time
that he won a very improbable victory
over a old crony democratic party
machine mayor and became mayor of
Burlington and what would you say has
changed from 2016 to 2020 in terms of
either the issues the personalities the
name recognition I mean how is 2020 for
Bernie different than four years ago
well one of the interesting things about
Bernie is that he has been incredibly
consistent in his beliefs in his values
and in what he's been promoting in terms
of what would be good for the country
for those last 40 years
but since 2016 I think the big
difference is that his name recognition
is huge and you know clearly he's
already leading the country based on all
the other candidates that have been kind
of following the positions that he
staked out in 2016
you know I firmly believe that if the
media gave Bernie the same amount of
coverage they gave Trump in the 2016
election that Bernie would be President
today so I think this time around he's
starting off way ahead of the game in
terms of name recognition in terms
you know an organization a campaign
organization he's way way ahead he was
kind of building on the fly last time
around so you know those of us working
on the campaign are feeling really
really good yeah one of the things I've
been talking about is that thanks to
Bernie a lot of ideas that were not
common ideas in the Democratic field in
2016 have been significantly
mainstreamed so whether they really
support it or not most of the Democratic
candidates now or at least paying lip
service to the idea of Medicare for all
or some other system that will achieve
full coverage when we talk about tuition
free public colleges and universities
there's a lot of issues that we can
thank Bernie for mainstreaming four
years ago but what I wonder is whether
the fact that those ideas have been
mainstreamed in some way hurts Bernie by
making the ideas no longer unique to
Bernie in the Democratic field well you
know it's interesting I think that being
authentic and being the originator goes
a long way with the public clearly
Bernie isn't just jumping on the
bandwagon he's promoting ideas that he
has deeply believed in and deeply fought
for for these past 40 years so I think
we welcome all these other candidates
supporting these incredibly good policy
initiatives and I look forward to Bernie
coming out with even more and better
ones
did you see the Town Hall that Bernie
did on CNN I guess now it was a couple
of weeks ago no I didn't you didn't okay
so i'll frame the question i I glad I
asked so I can frame the question
correctly do you feel as though so far
the Democratic National Committee is
interfering in the primary in any way
similar to what we saw in 2016
or do you believe that they are staying
out of it to the extent of picking a
favorite or leaning on someone or
against somebody else what's your
assessment of their presence and role in
the primary so far I believe the primary
so far you know is just barely getting
underway and I think the DNC has been
even-handed you know I certainly am
aware that there's there's kind of two
wings and the Democratic Party one
continues to be the Hillary wing and you
know I I imagine that there's a lot of
people on the DNC that are that are in
that wing which i think is now going to
become the Biden wing but you know
thanks to an incredible amount of work
by a whole lot of people since the last
Democratic convention there have been
some very significant changes in the DNC
you know particularly in terms of
super-delegates not being able to vote
on the first round of voting at the
convention and and I also think that
since the since since their finger on
the scale or shall I say they're they're
huge
foot on the scale was exposed last time
around I think they're a lot more
sensitive to to making sure that doesn't
happen this time yeah I hope you're
right it's sort of sad that it took this
shameful public thing that took place in
order for some of these rules to be
changed and and for hopefully things to
be moved around but I guess it's it's
it's better than not having the changes
what one way or the other you mentioned
Joe Biden let me talk about Joe Biden a
little bit as I told my audience last
week Bernie Sanders right now is leading
basically every poll for the 2020
Democratic primary
typically among candidates who have
declared Joe Biden has not declared as
of when you and I are talking right now
but in just about every one of those
polls Joe Biden is polling ahead of
Bernie
now there's one interpretation of those
polls which is that's basically name
recognition and if Biden declares as
soon as people realize he's not actually
that progressive his support will go
down the other side is if if Joe Biden's
doing this well now when he declares
he's gonna run away with it
what do you think I think clearly the
the energy amongst the Democratic
rank-and-file actually get out there and
volunteer and work for candidates and
that donate small dollar donations to
candidates is in favor of Bernie and the
progressive wing of the of the
Democratic Party you know there's no way
that Biden is ever going to turn out the
kind of crowds that that Bernie has
turned out and and actually if you look
at the most recent poll which I think
was by Emerson College amongst Wisconsin
voters Bernie even comes out ahead of
Biden specifically in within Wisconsin
you're saying that's correct okay yeah I
haven't I haven't seen that one what do
you think is responsible for the strong
polling numbers of Joe Biden
I think it's name recognition you know I
I think that you know if you just look
at even even Republicans and Democrats
everybody is saying we don't want
Washington insiders and Biden is you
know kind of the ultimate Washington
insider you know I have no doubt that he
will get a large
of big money donations but big money
donations also known as bribery is not
what's going to sway the the voting
public this time around what will they
be swayed by will it be a particular
issue will it be personality will it be
who can best go up against Donald Trump
which is a consideration for some voters
well I think getting Donald Trump out of
office as Bernie himself has said is
essentially job one and I think the way
to do that is to energize a huge base of
supporters and you know kind of mizzling
middle-of-the-road
kind of centrist policies is is not
gonna do that you know the other
interesting thing is that there's a
significant overlap between Trump voters
and Bernie voters really and and yeah
and and it's not surprising if you just
listen to Trump's election rhetoric last
time around he was for the little guy he
was for the working people he was not
going to cut your Social Security well
bet he would is it fair to say I don't
interupt is it fair to say Trump claimed
to be those things maybe is more precise
exactly he claimed to be those things
and voters that wanted those things had
a choice of either Trump the insurgent
or Hillary the establishment status quo
business as usual politician and and so
they they voted for God anything but the
status quo this time around I think
Trump voters many of them have seen that
the rhetoric
does not match the reality and if they
truly want somebody who's out for the
interests of of the little guy it's
burning okay let's talk about something
that in some left-wing circles I guess
you're not supposed to talk about but I
really want to talk about it with you
particularly because of how long you've
known Bernie which is the contingent of
2016 Bernie supporters that either voted
for a third party candidate for Donald
Trump or stayed home now just so you
know because you may you know we our
conversation was years ago I supported
Bernie Sanders in the primary and
ultimately cast a vote for Hillary
Clinton in Massachusetts where I live in
2016
question one are you concerned about
that contingent in 2020 question two
what do you think drives that decision
to support Bernie Sanders in the primary
and then to do something other than
voting for the Democratic nominee when
it gets to the general election well to
support Bernie Sanders in the primary I
certainly understand that one okay or
you're suggesting you're positing the
the situation whereby Bernie does not
win the primary and and then would
people who voted for him in the primary
vote for a different Democrat it's not
so much I'm positing it I'm sort of
thinking back to the small contingent
that did that in 2016 and the sort of
distant what maybe disproportionate
coverage of them given their actual size
well I think well firend last time
around nobody thought there was a chance
in hell that Trump was going to get
elected yes so they they didn't see a
vote you know they didn't see sitting
though sitting the election out creating
the problem that we've got today this
time around it's going to be pretty
clear to everybody that of you sit it
out we
got the same horror that we have today
and ain't nobody gonna be sitting this
election out yeah I think that's a fair
point I mean there were some people last
election who said if it's not someone
truly progressive it's it's Hillary or
Trump yes they're sort of different but
by and large it's not effectively
different now that we see what's
happened with the Supreme Court we're
seeing what's happened with climate
change or ignoring actually the threat
of climate change we're seeing what's
happening with the swamp feeling you're
suggesting that nobody at this point
would think that it's sort of irrelevant
who wins if it's not a truly progressive
candidate like Bernie that people would
realize the importance of participating
and voting no matter who the nominee is
well and and Bernie has said it in so
many words that's four that he support
whoever the Democratic nominee is that
the most important thing we can do for
our country is to get Trump out of
office what is next for the campaign in
terms of messaging and strategy we know
lots of Bernie's most important issues
Medicare for all is sort of at the
forefront there what what shifts can we
expect in terms of the focus on issues
if any in the coming months you know I'm
not really aware of much that's coming
down the pike I mean you this is like
the question that I always get about
what's the new flavor coming out you
know if I knew I couldn't tell you you
know but I but I think what is really
different this time around
and what what is really exciting to me
this time around is the the diversity in
terms of race and gender and ethnicity
in Bernie's team and it is so wonderful
to be working with my fellow co-chairs
yulian the mayor of
for no Reeko road Khanna and Indian by
ancestry a congressperson from
California and our the queen of the
co-chairs Nina Turner senator Nina
Turner from Cleveland an
african-american woman and it's it's a
beautiful thing to see and you know and
and I'm just so excited about the way
that Bernie has embraced diversity well
we have been following the campaign
closely and of course we will continue
to do it we've been speaking with one of
Bernie Sanders 2020 campaign national
co-chairs Ben Cohen really appreciate
you talking to me once again been good
talking to you David the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so last Monday I did a story where I
discussed that I had finished up my
taxes for 2018 and that as a result of
Donald Trump's new tax plan my effective
federal tax rate dropped about 13
percent it was like 26 point something
percent for the 2017 tax year and it
dropped to 22 point something percent
for the 2018 tax year about a 13 percent
drop and my focus in the clip was that
economically speaking it didn't really
make much sense for the US economy the
responses were so all over the place
misunderstanding how taxes work
misunderstanding how economics works
misunderstanding even what I was saying
that I gathered some of the more common
themes from the responses that I just
want to address and I rarely do these
sort of point/counterpoint response type
things where I do a clip and then people
respond and I respond to the responses
but there were so many responses to the
tax cut clip that were so fundamentally
flawed that I thought it would be useful
so these are this is not every argument
made about how stupid I am
but these are some of the more common
themes that I saw let's put the first
one up on the screen this is an argument
that I saw a bunch give back the money
to government anyway the government
needs it
for global warming this is the idea
which I actually mentioned in the video
which is David if you think your tax
rate should be higher just send in more
money to the IRS you can always do that
you can always send in more money if you
want it makes no difference whether I
choose to pay more this is not about the
amount of Taxation I believe is right
for me to pay this is about the fact
that economically speaking it doesn't
make sense to give me on the basis of
having passed through income and this
deduction that Trump put in place it's
not economically logical to give me a 13
percent tax cut that's what I'm saying
if I just write a check to the IRS yeah
they'll take the money but the money
isn't budgeted to be used in any kind of
stimulative way you can't run a country
on the idea that the people who think
they should pay more will send more
money in because
they might want to it's ridiculous I
mentioned it in the video it's just not
economic policy okay that's number one
can't even believe I have to address
that
it was in the video I said in the video
if you're gonna say David pay more
here's why it doesn't make sense okay
another theme that I saw in terms of
responses people talking about me
complaining about my taxes going down
for example Tim Brock 1000 on YouTube
saying behold the first guy to ever
complain about having a lower tax
invoice totally misses the point of the
segment I'm not complaining about paying
less in taxes what I'm saying is that if
I put aside what puts more or less money
in my pocket and I explain what's good
for the economy the economy is not
better off because certain business
income has been taxed at a lower rate or
there's a deduction for a portion of
business income the whole point is it
doesn't matter whether I like having
more money or not that that's exactly
the opposite of what the segment was
about it was about the economic impact
and why I would get a 13 percent tax cut
this got very quickly into another theme
about earning the money versus earning
the tax cut okay a lot of people
commented things like for example what
did I do to earn the money I earned
great question David this is straight
out of the libertarian playbook okay in
the segment I said what have I done to
earn this tax cut okay I got hundreds of
responses from people saying David you
earned the money by working this is a
total semantic game I get that I earned
the money by working the question is
what did someone in my specific
situation do to deserve getting a tax
cut versus people in other situations
getting tax increases or decreases once
again the responses are all about me
specifically it's an illustration of how
economic policy works and I'm pointing
out that it doesn't make economic sense
to cut the taxes of people in the
particular business owning situation in
which I find myself okay another theme
David just spend the money it'll be good
for the economy one example you do
realize that you can spend the money
that you earned right and spending this
money helps the economy it's okay to
spend your money this is the whole point
okay people with businesses who aren't
incorporating that tax cut into their
personal spending month-to-month are not
that likely to spend the money I did the
same thing I always do with my tax
refund I saved it this isn't a hugely
economically stimulative thing to do I
wasn't counting on that money i budgeted
for the business and for everything for
the year on the basis of not getting the
cut I don't buy random things when I get
a little extra money I save the money
and this is exactly why it is not a good
way to stimulate the economy and people
who are actually wealthy do you think
that they go and spend that money on
stuff in the traditionally economically
stimulative way no they don't
this is why this type of pass-through
business income tax cut doesn't make
sense and then lastly the charity
argument why don't you give your extra
money to charities that's perfectly fine
it does not end up being very
economically stimulative it does not
justify tax cuts for the rich the
question isn't what can David Pakman
come up with to do with money that
results from a lower tax rate at the end
of the year the question is what should
government policy be around how to best
tax and spend government revenues me
giving money to charity is fine but it's
not policy it's at my discretion only
part of that charity donation even goes
to doing the good that charities do
there's overhead and all sorts of other
stuff so it really doesn't make sense
and then the last one which we don't
have a screenshot of is David you should
just reinvest the money into the
business to grow the business
exponentially
stop people saying that online you don't
grow a business exponentially with a
single tax cut which is likely not even
going to be permanent since much of what
has been done by the new tax plan is
temporary anyway it would be really bad
planning to on the basis of a tax cut
one year start doing whatever it is that
these people imagine would be done with
the money so just a lot of nonsense
responses from people who just don't
really seem to understand what the point
is of pointing out at a policy level
what doesn't doesn't make sense rather
than can david pakman donate the money
to charity that's not really the issue
here we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
very good friends over at linguist who
make it possible to learn a foreign
language very quickly with their
personalized spaced repetition ai
algorithm I've been rehashing my French
and I've improved very quickly you can
try it out for free with no credit card
at Ling viscom slash Pakman that's Li ng
VI st.com slash Pakman thanks to them
for sponsoring the voice mail segment
and with no further delay let's get on
to a voicemail I offended someone or I
guess a guest offended someone a caller
offended someone in the audience here is
why they were offended hey David I was
surprised that you let that caller who
called in about 25 minutes into your
show who cost like 4 to 6 times he used
the GD word and you didn't call off I
was kind of offended by that I really
didn't like him as a caller the way he
said it and the fact that he did say it
I think he knew he was doing and he had
no intention of saying anything to you
have substance so when people like that
call either because they think they can
get you to pay some kind of fine if he's
fine depending on whether you go out to
broadcast stations or not I would cut
them off immediately and not clip with
their nonsense okay have a good night
okay
so there's a couple different issues
here one is someone be
individually offended by the use of the
term goddamn as far as allowing it in
the FCC stuff it's allowed by the FCC I
mean it's not the guidance we've gotten
is that we don't have to worry about
that it's the same as when if someone
just says you're acting like a horse's
ass that's allowed for our type of
programming on the stations that were on
but if someone turns that into the
7-letter version of the word that is not
allowed so there's kind of two different
issues here our broadcast stations are
fine that it so you're allowed to say
that there's not going to be any FCC
fines for that and number two in terms
of being offended I mean I'm sorry I
don't know its language people use we
don't really do that it it may not be
language that I regularly use but we're
not going to cut a call out of the show
because somebody use that word so I'm
sorry I'm sorry if people were offended
and I'm not being sarcastic when I say
that I'm not actually apologizing for a
callers use of the word but I feel bad
if somebody was offended
we've got a great bonus show for you
today david pakman.com slash membership
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will speak to you on the bubble
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]